dozens of people are unaccounted for
this morning after sudden and severe
storms washed some homes right off their
foundations a state of emergency has
been declared christina raffini is in
rural buckhannon county where flooded
roads are complicating rescue efforts
christina good morning
yeah good morning the flood waters have
receded in much of this area but what
they left behind is devastation as you
can see we're standing in what was once
the foundations of a home the home has
been picked up and thrown onto the
middle of the road behind us the decking
is on the truck and as you drive down
this strip there's debris everywhere
about 44 people are still unaccounted
for the sheriff's office has set up a
hotline that family members can call if
they're still looking for missing loved
ones
powerful flood waters washed away more
than a hundred homes tuesday devastating
this community in the foothills of the
appalachian mountains well it's just mud
slides trees and the road
water's been in the road and it's
houses in the road and it's just a mess
the storms caused landslides blocking
roads and washing out bridges
the state's emergency management said no
power landline or cell service was
available in some areas making it
difficult to contact dozens unaccounted
for so as they make their way back to
the shelter we'll do a reunification and
be able to check that box off on where
they
you know they lived
and and go basically house by house
and figure those things out
about 3 700 households were without
power wednesday morning according to the
local utility company but this region is
no stranger to severe weather last
august remnants of hurricane ida washed
away homes leaving one dead and now less
than a year later the storm-battered
community has been hit again
everything's gone
i mean it's a little community right
here people lost everything
and it's
it's sad
about 1300 people are still without
power this morning and officials are
hoping as that power comes back on as
people get self-service back there's no
cell service in this area they'll be
able to reach those missing loved ones
in the meantime the sheriff's office is
asking people to call that number if
they're looking for someone they love
tony